mr depp in these pictures that were
taken
before you got on the train ride for
your honeymoon where you claim that
misheard hit you and gave you a black
eye you have the exact same shadow or
sunburner mark under your left eye
the exact same mark don't you
that's the um
when you get a side light you see the
occipital bone
so
that is the exact area
yeah
and it's actually a side light will
cause that yeah well the picture's not
being taken from the side is it it's
being taken
no no no the lens in front yeah light on
the side right will cause that occipital
bone i believe it's called
to to
appear sunken just like lights on the
side of a train car correct
calls for speculation you can take that
down michelle that was in fact in the
dark
people on either side of me
i don't see where the light fill is from
the side there mr definitely can wait
for the next question next question next
question even the picture your team
chose to show you on that train
isn't accurate is it let's pull up
jackson calls for speculation let's pull
up exhibit 1859 please
1859 is that in evidence no your honor
mr deb this is this this is the same
picture the same um
the exact same scene
displayed in px 162
that you looked at this morning correct
that
looks
like my face has been the eyes have been
photoshopped oh okay bye so this this
this post from the eastern and oriental
express facebook page you're saying that
that's photoshopped
is that from their page
sure why wouldn't they let's pull them
up side by side please
you're on our move for the admission of
uh this exhibit we can just just have
the pictures we don't need the any
objection to the picture objection lack
of foundation lack of authentication
is that you in the photo mr doubt
it is me but it's clearly
your honor
anything after that first of all
um and um would ask for admission of
this photograph
all right just a photograph yeah you're
gonna we maintain our lack of
authentication lack of foundation all
right over objection about 1859 and
thank you your honor michelle what i'd
like to ask you to do please is to to
put
the picture
displayed as 1859
just
was admitted into evidence next to
px 162 that was shown to mr depp this
morning
okay you can pump those are both
inhabited
can you try to make them the same size
please
this is the exact same picture isn't it
mr depp
with radically different quality
and
no you answered my question
you answered my question sir thank you
appreciate it you're very welcome mr
depp you testified previously that the
vodka bottle that you allege
cut off your finger was a handle of
vodka correct
um yes right the second bottle there was
a
handle on it right yes
this bottle whatever it is to the extent
it's glass at all that's in the corner
of this room that's not a handle of
vodka objection calls for speculation um
i think you'll find that i said two
bottles
well actually what you testified to this
morning mr depp was that the bottle in
the corner was the handle
and there is no other bottle in the
picture is there no that's not what it
testified i testified that may i touch
the screen
yes
this is glass
this
is glass
and that's not a handle neither of those
are handles of vodka it's that big it's
broken the handles up the top
on those volca bottles sir
i mean
and none if you if you combine all that
glass on the floor that doesn't make up
the amount of glass and a handle of
vodka does it objection calls for
speculation i i'm not uh
if there's objection hold on i'll
sustain the objection next question
there is no picture of a handle of vodka
broken on that floor is there mr doubt
no i don't see it i see glass under this
chair here okay well
you tell this morning that you did see
it so it's good to get that
clarification let's no i didn't do this
you also testified this morning
that
you
yeah and i want to get this i want to
make sure that we're on the same page
here you testify bro does this refresh
your recollection that you said
i have a lot of love inside me and a lot
of anger inside me as well
if i love somebody then i'm going to
love them
if i'm angry and i've got to lash out or
hit somebody i'm going to do it and i
don't care what the repercussions are
anger doesn't pay rent it's got to go
it's got to be evicted
do i read that right
you did read that right yes thank you
you can take that down michelle please
now
mr depp you've also
claimed that um
you've said before that if if you want
to be with a woman sexually that she is
rightfully yours
haven't you
could you repeat that and you've also
said that could you repeat that please
yeah that if you want to be with a woman
sexually that she is rightfully yours
that's ludicrous
you've also said that with respect to
women that you want to be with you've
remarked i need i want i take haven't
you
equally as ludicrous no can you pull up
dx883 please
you can pull it what you like i've never
showed those words
there's not enough hubris in
me to say anything eight three eight
eight three your honor it's not next is
it empty it is not admitted yet okay
mr depp
these are text messages from you
to stephen duders on february 22nd 2017
correct um
this
no this looks nothing like me you might
have mistaken uh
mr depp we can show the full unredacted
you've looked at a number of text
messages in this case and the words him
as the identifier that's you correct in
every text message we've seen in this
case
yeah
sure it still doesn't mean it hasn't
been screwed with
that's not
anything
that i've ever said or written you want
to see the whole the whole thing
unredacted we can look at that too no
because you could have typed it up last
night no
i can assure you i didn't type it up
last night mr depp mr depp are you're
aware these are text messages
you can see the bottom right where it
says death and then it has a number
eight one two nine those are produced by
you in this litigation you understand
that right i understand that's great all
right michelle could you please
let's take a look at the top text first
mr depp on february 22nd 2017
you texted mr deuters
right
exactly
molly's [ __ ] is rightfully mine should
i not just bust in and remove its hinges
tonight
did i read that right
you're ready right and the one beneath
that you say
i want to change her understanding of
what it is like to be thrashed about
like a pleading mackerel
and then in all caps you write i need
i want
i take
did i read that right you read it right
but i did not write that okay
perhaps you wrote every other text that
you produced that came from you in this
litigation didn't you not necessarily
sometimes you give your people your
phone you claim that you
you somehow were responsible for her
getting the role uh with warner brothers
correct
that's what you testified to this
morning
you also
you also tried to get her fired
from aquaman didn't you
after the temporary restraining order
which question would you like me to
handle first one question sir you tried
to get her fired from the aquaman after
the temporary restraining order didn't
you
um well what is related to the story
about me just yes yes or no mr depp i i
don't i
suppose
i i can't please you with a yes or no
every single time that's a yes or no
question mr jeff you tried to get mister
fire didn't you answer's no all right
let's pull up um exhibit 821
this is a
this is a text message that you had with
your sister christie dembrowski she's
the first witness in this case right she
doesn't work at warner brothers she
can't fire amber
this is a text message you had with her
on june 4th 2016. isn't it
june 12th yes
your honor uh move for the admission of
exhibit 821 is redacted any objection
um
we would object on relevance grounds
your honor
overall that objection 821 in evidence
and on june 4th
2016
mr depp you texted your sister i want
her replaced on that wb film
did i read that right
you did her is referring to amber right
that's correct and wb is warner brothers
correct
again correct yes and then after you
sent this text to your sister
following the temporary restraining
order you reached out to guy silverstein
to have him fire amber correct
greg silverstein i'm sorry
um i don't recall reaching out to greg
silverstein you reached out to sue crawl
admirer
right i had vetted miss hurd
and
i i have vetted miss foreign
you reached out to greg silverstein to
get him to to try to get amber fire from
aquaman didn't you
excuse me aston answered
it's a yesterday question that he hasn't
answered yesterday all right
yes or no sir you reached out to greg
silverstein to try to get amber fired
from aquaman
second half of your question is wrong
sir you really reached out to them
because i vetted her no no mr depp you
reached out to sue crawford to get her
to to try to get her to
help you get amber fired from aquaman
didn't you
no and you reached out to kevin suzahara
to try to get him to help you get amber
fire from aquaman didn't you no